magic leap is a augmented reality
company founded in
florida in about 2010 and
their vision was huge absolutely huge
they wanted to bring some really really
cutting edge technology that was
previously only available in labs in
huge rooms and shrink all that down into
a form factor similar to a pair of
glasses that you could wear
it's really really cool technology and i
want to talk about
why they're in the news what they could
have done differently
and how they ended up where they are so
magic leap was founded by ronnie abavitz
in 2010
and to date they've raised over two
billion dollars from google and a bunch
of other venture capitalists as well as
large technology firms they recently
announced a large
swath of layoffs about 50 of their
workforce that's 1 000
jobs and they also announced that they
would be pivoting away from
consumer plans and instead focusing on
the enterprise
then about a month later in may they
announced that they had successfully
raised 350 million dollars
and that they wouldn't need to lay off
so many people but
then just a few days ago they announced
that the ceo and founder
would be stepping aside and that's
generally not a good sign for the
company
he's the one that laid down the vision
and obviously they're in a rough
situation if he has to move on and
they're bringing in new management so i
think this is an interesting case study
because
they raised so much money pre-product
market fit
but unlike a theranose or you know
another kind of
real buzzy startup that's raised lots of
money before getting customers
the founder here ronnie is the real deal
he founded mako surgical
which is another kind of hard tack
robotics company
they make surgical arms to help with
knee surgeries and hip replacements
and he sold this company for 1.65
billion dollars
just nine years after founding it to
stryker which is a very big medical
devices company
huge success obviously after an exit
like that
he could get in the room with any type
of investor and they'd want to hear him
out and see what his next vision was
ronnie is clearly incredible at
fundraising
there were multiple articles about how
much money he'd raised before
launching anything or really announcing
anything publicly
so when investors look to value a
company they're
hoping to look at profits if profits
aren't there then revenues might suffice
if revenues aren't there then you might
look at customers or
user traction but if the customers
aren't even there yet because you're
just completely pre-launched
really all you have to go off of is the
technology
and the people behind the project so in
magix leaps
example they were very focused on this
technology demo
and the people and the talent that had
joined the team to make this a reality
if you look around at people who had
done the demo
it was a very secretive process you
needed to sign a lot of non-disclosure
agreements but it sounds like you moved
into a large room
and the equipment was not in a glasses
form factor
at all it was maybe the size of a room
or a large table and it worked
incredibly well
everyone who tried it loved it and was
absolutely
taken aback by it and swore by it
but the vision was always to shrink that
technology down
to something much smaller that you could
wear on your face as a pair of glasses
and that was the real challenge and
that's why they raised so much money
to try and make that happen so the demo
promised a bunch of different things
retinal projection meaning the light
would be projected directly onto your
eyes as opposed to
say you looking at a screen they wanted
to have a wide field of view
deep depth of field so there were
various focal points that you could look
at
made it all look very very real
obviously all packed into a glasses form
factor
at a price that a consumer albeit a
high-end one could afford
but again shrinking that tech down was
just super difficult
one of the biggest problems was the
field of view it was very narrow
and as you tilted your head left or
right objects would clip
in and out of the scene so when i first
heard about this
retinal projection idea i thought it was
just
marketing speak i thought that they had
basically
looked at the science behind what
happens when you look at a led tv
which technically the light does come
from the tv directly to your retina
that that is technically accurate and i
thought that they had just rebranded
looking at a screen or bouncing
something off of a piece of glass into
your eye
as retinal projection but it appears
that they actually
had built a true retinal projection
system
they just couldn't shrink it down so
naturally tons of investors who
looked at this demo and felt this
amazing experience
we're immediately comparing it to the
iphone and multi-touch and just kind of
the
exciting new frontier of technology that
could be unlocked by
a device like this but when i think
about
the iphone launch i think back to the
original steve jobs presentation
i focus on the fact that he had three
main value propositions
the iphone was going to be better than
your ipod better than your current phone
and it was also going to serve as an
internet communicator
or web browser and i think augmented
reality
needs a three-prong approach i think
gaming and these interesting
creative demos aren't enough it also
needs to supplant
video it needs to supplant your tv or
your home theater
it needs to supplant your multiple
monitor setup that you might use for
work
at an affordable price point and i think
that once we get to a point where
vr or ar is able to actually
compete with the existing technologies
be they monitors or
tvs then you'll see really mass adoption
and then all of the creators will come
and start taking advantage of
the broader technology and what's
available with a new device
so when you look at what happened with
the iphone they were able to introduce
very quickly
a product that was better than your
existing cell phone it did the job of
making phone calls reliably it did the
job of handling voicemail and it
actually did that
more efficiently with visual voicemail
and of course as the ipod
it evolved that to include multi-touch
and a larger library
and eventually internet connectivity so
there were a lot of ways that it was
advancing existing devices and replacing
them
so to the consumer they weren't just
buying
a phone that one day would have a large
app ecosystem and they could
maybe download instagram if that was
ever even created
instead they were very easily able to
justify the purchase as
this will replace my current phone it
will replace my ipod
and i'll also be able to browse the web
on this now the browsing the web part is
very important
because it allowed them to
wrap a whole host of benefits around an
existing ecosystem which was
the web the safari web browser on ios
was so mature
that it could render the new york times
website just as you saw it on desktop
and that was something that no mobile
phone could really do at the time
so that was a very interesting approach
because it allowed them to
essentially have a whole host of content
available to the product
immediately there was no real waiting
period
so the analogy with vr and ar here in
gaming
might look like a developer kit that
allows
a traditional developer who's developing
for ps4
or xbox or pc to be able to bring their
content
very easily to vr or ar
much like websites were immediately
viable
on the iphone you might need some
translation software you might need some
developer kits but being able to bring a
huge
library of content and titles to the
device would immediately add value
for someone who maybe doesn't have a tv
or doesn't have a ps4 or doesn't have
monitors and a
gaming rig if they can buy this even if
it's a thousand dollars that might
actually be
cheaper for them so i think that that is
something that
these products need to focus on before
they have their quote unquote iphone
moment
so obviously magic leap is in a lot of
trouble it's the ceo's out
they're potentially laying people off
they're pivoting it doesn't seem like
they've been able to shrink down that
initial demo
in an effective way it seems to be
mostly r d at this point
but my hopes for the future of ar are
still really high i really hope that
this
doesn't cause a winter or some sort of
pullback in investment
you know some of these projects can move
into big tech
some of them can move into the
government and some of them can move
into university research labs but i do
think startups
can have an impact in these spaces so i
really hope that this doesn't mean
that we're not going to see another hard
tech company get
funded in the next five years i i really
hope that
people don't see this as a massive
failure for the industry as a whole
i do think that there's a valuable
lesson here though in
building too much hype before you go
live and you have something that
can actually be used by a consumer the
gap between
the demo and the reality was so wide
with magic leap
they just had an impossible hurdle to
jump over it was very very difficult
for them to bring something to market
and when they finally did they were met
with a lot of criticism and a lot of
negative reviews
because they created so much hype that
they weren't able to fulfill
i'm still super excited about virtual
reality and augmented reality
and i think that if they can solve some
of those other use cases like work
or home theater that the adoption will
be so much higher
ultimately it comes down to an economic
equation for most consumers
if this device can actually save them
money and get them a better experience
they're going to buy it
the amount of people that are gonna
spend a thousand dollars two thousand
dollars on a product that
only has a few demos and not a lot of
content and doesn't actually replace any
of the technology that they currently
have
is very small but as soon as you allow
people to replace
something existing with something that's
better even if it's incremental
the adoption is going to be huge so
that's what i'd like to see from magic
leap
i hope that they can pull through this
and wind up shipping some amazing stuff
i'd really like to be using this on a
daily basis but
unfortunately the product's just not
there yet and
it sounds like they've had some really
tough setbacks and their initial vision
didn't really pan out
but i hope that you know maybe they have
to sell off some patents
maybe some other people pick up the
research but i hope it continues because
the the vision here is incredible and i
hope that it pans out
thanks for listening to this if you have
any comments uh please let me know i'd
love to know what you think about magic
leap and
augmented reality and virtual reality
more broadly thanks a lot